can I have the coffee now oh please
think let's talk about tattoos hey
what's up GQ I am a little I'm gonna
show you some of my tattoos so get ready
yeah I've been like super open mind
since I was very young
I always wanted to get it - - and I got
it when I was 14 years old I have it
here in my leg and my left leg is the is
my name is maluma and if you guys don't
know my loom is because my mom's name is
Margie my dad's name is Louise and my
sister's name is Manuela so I took the
first two letters of each name my mom
she she got super mad with me but when
she saw the meaning of my tattoo she was
like oh my god it's too big but I'm
gonna accept it
because it's your family there was a
great idea for me to get my first tattoo
[Music]
just leave I did with this guy in Bogota
his name is Sara he's a super close
friend the first time that I got him in
my left arm was this magia which is the
name of my first album and then my like
my first really big tattoo was the
Buddha I loved Buddha because the way he
he used to think all his insane answers
or all his teachings I'm Catholic but
sometimes I love taking the best things
of every religion that's what that's why
I got the Buddha in my left arm after
that I met this guy Stephane Alcantara I
met him in Miami we were talking about
everything but tattoos and then I was
like bro you know what I want to give
you my my right arm so yeah he's working
on it right now I have these elephants
the meaning of these elephants are my
family if you see the reflection in the
water this is my dad
this is me my sister and my mom I wanted
to remind that even if there are divorce
we have to keep together
and this is Hercule is my horse my first
horse ever and yeah I know there are a
beautiful body super painful off and
then I got the all it means wisdom for
me is like one of the most important
tattoos I get because it's a super
spiritual to because like a kind of
protection all these bad vibes and bad
energies that are around the world and I
feel like Institute helped me a lot like
trying to control it it's like a like a
Japanese house right there's a sanctuary
so I feel always at home when I look at
him when I did I add the flowers to and
under the winds and everything that that
you can see or they
there's a lion that was painful too huh
yeah but I love it absolutely is one of
my favorite tattoos I have I was always
having like a very difficult time my lab
and I was super super young and I needed
some strength so that's why I got it
before a successful man there is always
an incredible woman
that's why I wanted to have this girl
like holding my back it could be my mom
it could be my girlfriend my grandmother
and then I have this rose
it represents a respect to the woman I
feel there I get it stop listening to
other people like like no just just do
things I love and and trying to find
your in your essence the things that you
want to get in your you skin face it
that hardcore yeah that's so much my mom
she would i love besides when you get up
like this neck tattoo like here facial
expression they changed like crazy i
have a friend has like a face like a
little face here so just like you're
talking to two different people who know
i think you know it's super weird yeah
I'm not gonna say never because you
never know but I wouldn't do it
[Music]